I'm in flux with my boyfriend what's in
flux me because I had assumed so here's
what I did burn it to the ground
a little bit when we first broke up well
I learned on your Instagram that this
boyfriend that you talked about on the
show before very much in love with
previously and on-chip she wouldn't stop
right right
I was mad I'm so in love with them I
still want to marry him I just think we
have some fundamental problems so we got
to work out well there were posts about
you guys breaking up it was post
disappeared
right I was in a mood right you you
broke it with him he broke up with you I
broke up with him but I was mad at the
way that he yelled at me on Saturday
night he yelled at me and he clapped his
hands like those like cheerleaders clap
their hands he's clapping like he did
the like you need to listen to me I
don't know guys what are you doing I won
it was my fault I tried to have a
conversation with him when he got home
drunk at 3:30 in the morning what was
the conversation 5:30 in the morning the
night before okay that's not
conversation you wanted to you wanted to
reprimand you wanted to fight with him
well you're the girlfriend you want to
know hey where have you been all night
crazy I mean I think 5:30 is a pretty
hard sell 5:30 stuff kind of late what
was he doing friends he's just trying to
get some some fresh coos that's all some
strange good for you you're right
let's try shut the [ __ ] up buddy
probably is right Roy I'm sure your
pussy's fine it's you know what it's fun
to get some new you'll never know Troy I
don't need to know yeah but you know
what when was the last time Troy
you hung out with your dude friends
until 5:30 exactly
Jim do you hang out with the dudes the
bros until 5:30 no and here's what you
got to do and it might sound like tough
medicine ya wanna see these been cheatin
smell his dick that's how I tell my
girlfriend's been cheatin
there was a song let me smell yo dick
toy when they come home at 5:30 it's
yeah the friends you got it more than
smile I think you gotta suck it because
you can't let's say he used a condom to
[ __ ] someone you can't smell that but
you can taste yeah yeah I mean look at a
certain point you're hanging out with
your buds well then let me suck your
dick babe let me make you [ __ ] really
fast and then we're gonna talk what were
you texting him while he was out no I
didn't text him once I let him I was
letting him live not until 5 a.m. I mean
once it gets to like 4 a.m. and you're
just hanging out with dudes it's almost
like what are we doing here together
it's gonna go weird like nothing were
you living together
nah no but I was at his place that week
I like we had plans to take a hit class
the next day
ladies a hit class high-intensity had
high intensity interval training like
we're gonna work out we're gonna work at
9:00 a.m. you know Angie wait did he
wake up for the workout oh I certainly
did not Sam
thank you for asking he snored like a
[ __ ] pig yeah B get that workout in
the night before you know what I'm sayin
some string now he came home at 5:30 and
what I did was I showed him my phone to
show what time it was and I was like oh
is this new couples curfew cool
you know like but he was drunk yeah so
he didn't think that was funny but I was
just trying to be funny but he's a young
man too is any how old is he he's 30 oh
she's not that young no no okay so he
comes home at 5:30 you're laying there
did he text you back when you texted him
at 5:00 all of a sudden he's coming home
oh just on my way Oh weird that you
texted me I'm right outside and he was
with a friend they both came back I bet
they did so how did you break up with
him what'd you say I mean I sort of like
like the next day go I like did my own
thing and then when needs come came home
again at 3:30 I was like what's like Oh
second I know right yeah I was like
what's you know and he just was like he
yelled at me so that I just left well do
you guys have standing plans or
something like that then we sort of
we're gonna reconcile I like you hang
out together is that what like the
general consensus is here we're gonna
date and then on the weekends we'll hang
out separately and you just come home
when you come home
I mean that's what I think we're trying
to figure out my thing is is I'm so busy
I worked so much that like there's
designated boyfriend time in my life and
I want to spend that time like winding
down like affectionate with a boyfriend
having sex and it's like if you're
available during those times like good
but if you're not like I'm gonna go out
boyfriend time with someone else but it
does make sense like you have a just
because your schedule is opposite if if
there was like a person who worked
nights every night and you work during
the day that person yeah my thing is
like if your social life is a priority
to you like that's not cool I think it's
such a turn-off to me your xxx boyfriend
that's what I mean attention guys he
does every time call me every time you
start is amazing I wouldn't say amazing
it gets old obviously my pussy's amazing
cuz my personality is difficult yeah
that's actually great yeah yeah I have
some redeeming quality right why you so
why you so why you so ornery over there
with me so I think you see through he's
just pulling your pigtails yeah I want
you to like him
[Laughter]
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]